lo que queremos hacer en este vídeo es
obtener práctica al estimar el resultado
de problemas con divisiones de varias
cifras nos piden estimar el resultado de
dividir 794 entre 18 ahora si quieren
obtener la respuesta exacta tendrían que
hacer una división larga a usar una
calculadora pero el objetivo es obtener
práctica al estimar el resultado pausa
en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo sin
usar lápiz o papel muy bien hagamos dos
juntos les diré cómo lo hago en mi mente
mi mente dice que 794 está muy cerca de
800 y que 18 está muy cerca de 20
yo diría que esto es casi lo mismo que
dividir 800 entre 20
el resultado es exactamente igual no
pero estos números son muy cercanos a
los que tenemos aquí y es más fácil para
mí dividirlos en mi cabeza por ejemplo
si lo hiciera solamente en mi cabeza
diría bueno 100 entre 20 es igual a 5
entonces 800 entre 20 es igual a 40 otra
manera de pensar en esto
800 sobre 20 si dividimos el numerador y
el denominador entre 10 es lo mismo que
80 sobre 2 que es igual a 40 por
supuesto que dividir 794 entre 18 no es
exactamente 40 pero el resultado es muy
cercano a 40 especialmente si vemos las
opciones que tenemos aquí estoy segura
de que estará más cerca de 40 que de 80
que de 4 y por supuesto que de 400 así
que nos vamos con esta respuesta
hagamos otro ejemplo para asegurarnos de
obtener práctica una vez más nos piden
estimar 722 dividido entre 68 traten de
hacerlo pausa en el vídeo y traten de
encontrar la respuesta en su mente bueno
lo que yo haría sería decir 722 está muy
cerca de 700 y 68 es muy cercano a 70 y
luego hacer esto en la mente es muy
directo 700 entre 70 es igual a 10 lo
bueno es que hay una opción que está muy
cerca de lo que aproximamos ahora si no
encontramos una respuesta exacta aquí no
hay problema porque recuerden que es una
aproximación deberán encontrar la
respuesta más cercana al resultado que
ustedes estimaron pero quien escribió
esta pregunta tuvo un proceso de
pensamiento muy similar dijo muy bien
722 es muy cercano a 700 y 68 está muy
cerca de 70 esto es aproximadamente
igual a dividir 700 entre 70 terminamos